[Music]
first up my delicious pan-fried pork
chops with sweet and sour peppers
whether it's in the restaurant or even
at home one of my golden rules for
producing fantastic food is learning to
cook with confidence this recipe is so
straightforward but tastes absolutely
amazing
pan on
get that nice and hot
you think of the sort of density of a
pork chop how it needs a little bit of
help
sweet sour Peppers go brilliantly well
first slice the peppers that's the flat
side of the pepper so stand it up try a
slice a pepper on the side is a
nightmare there's the center
start off
it's almost like sort of peeling an
orange go all the way around
and down
and look I see one
now place the pepper down
three finger rule one finger in front
two behind pinky holding it down thumb
holding it nice and flat the flatter the
vegetables the more confident you are
when you slice so
don't worry about the speed
just let the knife do the work
take your time
speed comes the most important thing
to get your Technique right
onion
now sweet sour peppers
olive oil in
I'm going to saute them which is just
the chef's term for shallow frying on a
high heat for maximum taste
some salt and pepper add a tablespoon of
sugar sugar helps to break down the
peppers quicker but caramelize the
onions frying them in a frying pan
perfect that's one of the sort of basic
essential tools of any kitchen because
it's so multi-purpose great for sauteing
tossing grapes for cooking fresh on meat
push away and pull back push away and
pull back that hissing is something you
need to hear constantly because
the minute that's gone your peppers and
your onions start to boil and you really
want them to soak it
you've now start to see it listening in
a way that it's starting to caramelize
Sugar's working beautifully
that's ready for the red wine vinegar
in
smells incredible it helps to stain the
peppers as well look at the glaze now
you see the sugar
it's worked as magic turn down the gas
and add a couple of tablespoons of fresh
extra virgin olive oil
let them stew for two to three minutes
now I want to make the peppers nice and
light some sort of sweet aromatic just
roll the basil almost like a big cigar
slice
basil in
and then literally cook it out for 30
seconds I want them off
[Music]
okay pan back on
and now for pork chops I want to make
sure they don't curl up in the pan they
start cutting up in the pan they're
going to cook unevenly
a few simple cuts through the Rind means
the chop stays flat and Cooks evenly
Point The Knife Down
flip through it's seasoned beautifully
nice large shards of pepper punch that
through lightly guaranteed that
seasoning
is going to stay there hot pan touch
garlic and touch of thyme the garlic
take a couple of clothes
don't peel it don't chop it just knife
on
crush it
olive oil in just starting to smoke
top of the chop in
and lay away from it
nice
keep that heat in the pan
the garlic in there early
a nice fragrant bunch of thyme
see how the pork has stayed nice and
flat turn that over look at that
beautiful
I want a little bit of thyme underneath
the
start squeezing that garlic out I want
the flavor coming out
butter in
thin slices of butter
tilt the pan and baste
so I'm sort of speeding up the cooking
process at the same time I'm keeping the
pork chop really nice and moist
and now look at the color of that butter
it's almost like sort of a nut brown
check the color on the other side it's
useful
when they're that thick three and a half
to four minutes each size 30 seconds
from now they're going to be medium so
I'm going to take them out and let them
rest
the secret to perfectly moist pork chops
is letting them rest almost as long as
they're cooked in the pan
when I spoon
of these Peppers basil smells incredible
keep that garlic on there be generous
with that vinaigrette from the peppers
because it really is incredible
do two things simple like that pork and
peppers
and your conference is going to shoot
through the roof a stunning pork chop
with sweet and sour Peppers
first up my flavor packed Lamb with fry
bread whether I'm cooking high-end
dishes or rustic dishes trust me it all
has to be impressive so this lamb dish
proves that you don't have to spend a
fortune to create delicious food
thank you
first off put the pan on
this is a lamb steak and it's cut just
above the leg just here because you can
see that delicious bone running through
the center and that's full of marrow so
that just gives the lamb a nice Added
Sweet flavor just take your knife cut
through each end this stops the lamb
steak from buckling so therefore it
Cooks evenly and colors beautifully so
and pepper
lamb needs quite a lot of help with the
pepper so I'm quite generous with the
pepper and just Pat that down the Pan's
just under Smoke on the outside now put
the oil in get that pan really nice and
hot because this is a cheap cut so I'm
depending on the color of the lamb steak
to really sort of impart a lot of flavor
doesn't always want to hear you can't
hear that noise don't drop the stake in
put a little bit of garlic in there not
chopped garlic this whole close the
garlic lightly crushed
don't even waste time peeling them in
tongs left up a bit of fat around the
back that's the top of the leg tilt the
pan and let all that fat render
rendering is a chef's term that means
melting the fat it works brilliantly
when you're cooking a rib eye as well
turn it over
now it looks like an expensive cut and
we've got that nice even sear all over
as it's cooking just tilt the pan and
base
and base in the lamb steak just means
you're sort of adding all that nice
scented garlic olive oil back into the
lamb useful
now take the lamb out let the lamb rest
station
[Music]
now for the perfect rustic Crouton so
this Bread's quite firm a couple of days
old
slice it straight down the center
[Music]
dice it up put it into a bowl
season it beautifully
[Music]
from there and add some milk sounds
strange adding milk to a crouton but it
just gives it that nice rich creamy
texture and just let that milk sort of
absorb into the bread while that's
soaking I'm gonna make the dressing go
back to that initial garlic that was in
the pan look at that beautiful into the
pest and water anchovies
anchovies go brilliantly well with lamb
I want that nice salty vinegary flavor
and a bit of kick some Capers a little
baby caps very sweet
now just pound that to a nice paste
smells incredible next some Dijon
mustard a nice teaspoon and a half in a
little bit of red wine vinegar two
tablespoons and then our extra virgin
olive oil
now
it's got that heat in there got a nice
roasted garlic a real hearty chunky
vinaigrette that sort of seeps into that
lamb
fresh parsley
crunch up the parsley delicious flavor
parsley in
nice
now get your pan hot for the croutons
olive oil in the pan
grab the croutons and squeeze all that
excess milk out not too hard I don't
want them dry
and in
[Music]
and then just fry them and the milk
inside these croutons give it a nice
spongy creamy delicious flavor
that's the color I want
nice now take them out and lightly drain
them a little bit of kitchen roll onto
the board out
[Music]
plateman just take this amazing
vinaigrette and spread it get those
croutons listen to them
my little Boulders hitting the plate the
lamb sit that on
next one
on the rest of the croutons
on I use all those little bits and my
chef in Paris would kill me right now if
you saw me using those because they're
the ugly scraps that customers should
never see but but they're the best bits
croutons on and then just
drop that sauce and all those little
bits
of the Lamb
and there that is a perfect way
of taking a cheap cut
is the Premier League of dishes
[Music]